un conseil d'agglomération plutôt calme
en cette fin de mois de septembre saint
quentin en yvelines reprenait le chemin
des délibérations au moment où plusieurs
conseils municipaux ont été chamboulées
on n'est pas inquiet vous avez senti
d'ailleurs ce soit et même eu un petit
complément financier qu'on a donnée
parce qu'eux on avez de bons résultats
ce sont deux choses n'ont pour l'instant
ça se passe plutôt bien
à cinq mois des élections municipales le
conseil d'agglomération voit une
nouvelle vice-présidente être nommé
daniel vialla élus à guyancourt récupère
le poste laissé vacant par
marie-christine le tarnec est
démissionnaire ce schéma il était
apprécié de tout le monde aussi bien les
maires de gauche que les maires de
droite
donc je pense qu'on va pas changer
quelque chose qui fonctionne
ils ont en plus des vrais délégation
l'équipe de guyancourt voilà je joue de
temps en temps on a on a une différence
sur un dossier etc
mais on en parle et on construit
ensemble ces affiches sur une issue
positive
parmi les délibérations un plan de
déploiement du numérique scolaires
inscrits dans le contrat yvelines
territoire du département d'un montant
de 7 millions d'euros saint quentin en
yvelines y investira plus d'un million 5